merci beaucoup bonjour à tous alors
effectivement on a parlé des bassins de
délinquance on a parlé de la préfecture
de police on nous avons évoqué le grand
paris tout ça dans la perspective on le
sait bien des élections présidentielles
de 2017
il ne faut pas oublier la france des
territoires parce que aujourd'hui si on
enlève l'île de france qui vient d'être
largement débattue le la gendarmerie est
présente sur 60 % des citoyens qui vont
être appelés à déposer un bulletin dans
l'urne dans un peu plus d'un an
donc c'est important certes il ya des
problématiques qui sont propres aux
grandes métropoles mais aujourd'hui on a
le sentiment qu'il y à une orge page
je veux pas jouer certains grands
anciens mais je vais quand même prononcé
le mot une certaine fracture et le on
doit tout faire pour chercher pourquoi
il y à un vote aussi contestataires un
vote front national et de l'abstention
dans ces territoires
parce que lorsque l'on parle de sécurité
nos concitoyens ne s'y retrouve plus on
parle de sécurité et on leur explique le
grand paris on leur explique les
problématiques de grandes agglomérations
mais il n'ya pas que ça 60 % de nos
électeurs
demain ne seront pas concernés par ces
problématiques
ils sont dans les territoires ils sont
la cible de prédateurs ils sont la cible
de ces vols que nous avons déjà évoqué
et donc il faut que l'on pense
effectivement à les ménager il faut que
l'on ait un discours qu'il puisse
comprendre lorsque l'on lorsqu'on leur
parle de bassins de délinquance ils le
comprennent
mais c'est leur bassin qui les
intéressent donc oui il faut continuer
le travail qui a été entrepris à partir
de 2002 sur l'airé des redéploiements
entre la police et la gendarmerie
bien sûr il faut continuer à travailler
en ce sens et il faut travailler en ce
sens dans le bon sens qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui la
france a la chance d'avoir deux forces
de sécurité une un statut militaire une
un statut civil
ces forces sont armés par des gens qui
sont aussi vaillant d'un côté que de
l'autre
mais ces gens travaillent différemment
parce qu'ils peuvent travailler
différemment parce qu'ils ont des
statuts différents et donc il ya un
statut qui se prêtent plus
particulièrement au contrôle de zone ce
qu'on appelle contrôle de zone c'est de
la terminologie militaire c'est je suis
responsable d'une zone sur cette zone il
se passe un certain nombre de choses et
pour assurer la tranquillité publique en
lien avec les élus locaux sous la la
responsabilité la direction du préfet et
là effectivement je rejoins ce qu'a dit
monsieur goujon il faut un chef il faut
un responsable et ce responsable
aujourd'hui c'est le responsable de
l'ordre public c'est le préfet de
département et donc sous la
responsabilité du préfet
le chef qui peut contrôler et de vastes
zones et bien fait c'est le encore une
fois je ne dis pas ne croyez surtout pas
que je fasse une comparaison peu les
gendarmeries
ce que je veux dire c'est que le
caractère militaire qui est qui est
celui des gendarmes se prête
particulièrement au contrôle de zone sur
de vastes zones alors que l'organisation
de la police qui est la sienne se prête
tout particulièrement aux vastes
ensembles fortement urbanisée donc tant
que nous pourrons redéployer police et
gendarmerie pour permettre à des
policiers nationaux
de travail et de la meilleure façon sur
les zones fortement urbanisées et à des
gendarmes militaires de contrôler les
zones du territoire nous pourrons gagner
la lutte contre contre la délinquance ce
que je voudrais ensuite dire s'est il
faut effectivement et là il y a du
travail à faire pour dans la perspective
de 2017
il voyait effectivement veiller à
accroître les moyens de ses agents
publique policiers gendarmes
nous le savons les finances de l'état ne
permettront pas de faire un plan
marshall sur les investissements sur les
investissements et donc il faut
travailler sur l'argent
sur des notamment sur les avoirs
criminels
pour faire court qu'est ce que les
avoirs criminels les avoirs criminels
c'est quelque chose qui a été mis en
place ces dernières années qui permet
d'aller toucher le délinquant sur son
portefeuille il faut augmenter la
possibilité de frapper le délinquant sur
le portefeuille
ça a déjà été évoqué c'est le souhait de
dmr que nous avons vu passer
c'est effectivement ce qui est le plus
prégnant
après la peine de prison donc frapper
les délinquants au portefeuille et
mettre en place un dispositif législatif
et réglementaire qui permettra d'aller
chercher tout ou partie quand je dis
tout c'est une boutade au moins une
partie de ses avoirs criminels pour
permettre l'équipement des forces de
sécurité qu'il s'agisse des véhicules
etc etc
ensuite un poids et j'en ai fini bruno
un point important qu'il faut que vous
ayez en tête quand on parle de recentrer
les forces de l'ordre sur leur mission
prioritaire
il faut bien penser que lorsque l'on dit
on va transférer les transfèrements à
l'administration pénitentiaire
ayez en tête que ça n'est jamais un
transfert brut c'est à dire que hier la
police et la gendarmerie avait un
certain nombre de tp des effectifs qui
avait en charge cette mission
lorsqu'on bascule la mission sur
l'administration pénitentiaire bien
évidemment l'administration
pénitentiaire ne fait pas ça avec les
gens qui avaient en charge le travail
dans les établissements pénitenciers il
a fallu que police et gendarmerie
transferts les effectifs qui étaient
dédiés à cette mission au profit de
l'administration pénitentiaire pour
quelle est la capacité sous enveloppe
constante je dirais de remplir cette
mission
sauf que c'était pas complètement
stupide de confier cette mission à la
police et à la gendarmerie c'était le
dispositif le plus économique en ce sens
qu'il y avait des policiers et des
gendarmes partout quand il va les
transferts un détenu de assure b on
prenait le fonctionnaire de a et ils
allaient l'emmener sur b il revenait à
sa place aujourd'hui l'administration
pénitentiaire à des groupes un peu
partout qu'elle envoie remplir ses
missions
c'est moi économie donc il faut à chaque
fois qu'on parle de transferts
bien pensé aux conséquences économiques
dans le cadre d'un budget qui est malgré
tout très contraint des décisions qui
convient de prendre voilà c'est ce que
je voulais vous dire merci mon général